Eaton's gate thinks they can just roll
into town and take the sauce they're
gonna be taught a hard lesson let's go
far cry 5 will let you team up with a
real-life cop buddy or one of three NPC
guns for hire
grace Armstrong Nick Wright or boomer
whether you're a fan of badass
gun-toting ladies brave pilots
patrolling the skies or faithful furry
friends a buck revived has you sorted if
you're arming an eyeing of a witch
gun-for-hire is the one for you stay
tuned to see how each of them play make
sure you also check out our impressions
where we talk about all the coolest
stuff you can get up to in Far Cry 5 for
now though let's help you decide who
your partner in crime is going to bait I
mean we both know you're gonna pick the
dog but I'm gonna roll the rest of the
video anyway
the Piggy's got a simple mo take what
they need want and burn the rest if we
don't stop him Hope County's going to be
ashes and a lot more people are gonna
suffer
Roger
good field of view on his tower that's
useful
[Music]
our project
[Music]
no surviving ahead like
[Music]
halfway through these nutjobs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]